[Music]
okay guys I know that you all have been
waiting a little bit but June has
arrived
Thank You June for finally showing up
yep about time what does this have for
doing here Schubert can't fight his own
battles
whatever the goal for today is to make
communication between the two of you
hopefully improve all I care about is
what is best for Lana and right now
sugar bear ain't that the action that
he's considering would be a legitimate
visitation action along with that there
would be a child sport assessment made
Jun lives in this Vegas house and we try
to save money for our honeymoon so why
would we have to pay her child support
it just makes no damn sense now part of
Mike filing a legitimation action would
be to establish that he's will be
recognized as a Lana's legal father in
the state of Georgia is there any
concerns that I need to know about that
he may not be her biological father has
there ever been a DNA test done
no hmm Schubert couldn't keep his wing
bang in his pants my question is is
there any more kids other that he
doesn't support do you have any concerns
that a DNA test would be needed I'm
confident as you use my daughter I don't
think we're gonna need a test for that
Jun lies about everything
for babies by four different daddies it
would hurt mine if he found out Alana
was not his but we need to find out the
truth and there's only one way we can do
that
[Music]
you